Pedro Castillo sigue en la cuerda floja
[Aplausos]
la fiscal general de Perú Patricia
Benavides presentó una denuncia
constitucional en su contra en el
congreso en la que se acusa al
presidente de liderar una organización
criminal Además del tráfico de
influencias y colusión agravada pero
anunciar
de la existencia de una presunta
organización criminal
enquistada en el gobierno
la fiscal también aseguró que ha habido
una constante y feroz obstrucción a la
justicia por parte de castillo y la
organización criminal que presuntamente
lidera la de este martes no es la única
investigación que señala el presidente
de corrupción el Ministerio Público ya
abierto cinco
pero la Constitución de Perú estipula
que el presidente solo puede ser juzgado
por casos de traición a la patria o por
impedir elecciones por lo que la actual
denuncia constitucional es un
procedimiento especial que se aplica
exclusivamente a altos funcionarios
Castillo aseguró que la denuncia se
trata de una nueva modalidad de golpe de
estado que se ha venido gestando desde
la fiscalía al mismo tiempo reiteró su
inocencia y su compromiso con el pueblo
peruano y el día de hoy
se está haciendo una acusación
constitucional
sabiendo que la propia constitución
le da prerrogativas al gobierno
para conducir el país
y que
según ellos
están fundamentando una acusación que
jamás hemos cometido el proceso ahora
está en manos del Congreso que decidirá
la suerte del mandatario las
investigaciones iniciadas y las
múltiples acusaciones de corrupción han
generado un descontento con el
presidente que tiene una desaprobación
que ronda el 70